- The reason I win,
often,
is because I'm not worried
about the person in the middle.
Got it?
- [Man] Yeah.
- I didn't change for them.
They changed for me.
Why?
Because I focused on you.
(bass music)
- Yeah.
- You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
I'm super excited to be here.
Obviously, it's funny,
this is so literal to my world
and it's fun because
yesterday I was in Boston
and I spoke to 600
jewelry store owners
and it felt really warm to
me because they're merchants.
They own a single store
and they sell stuff.
And
that, obviously, is very
much where I come from.
And then I get to get
behind it to have this event
where so many of the people in this room,
the far majority, are doing
what I'm currently doing.
And yesterday was a
lot of fun to reminisce
and challenge myself to
think about what did I do
when I had no money?
Which is really basically
the framework of the talk,
which is a lotta people in this room
that are familiar with my work,
I talk about a lotta progressive
things, a lot of things.
But the reality is
I always remember when I kept
trying to change the narrative
in 2014, '15, '16, which is
I didn't build Wine Library
through just social media.
I did direct mail.
It was search.
It was email marketing.
And I took it way back because
I knew that a lotta people
in the room had no marketing budget.
And it made me remember something
that is super fun for me,
which is literally week
one, out of college,
no marketing budget,
I printed a bunch of 20% off
by the case of wine things
on a picture I made in
some sort of version
of old school, not even Photoshop yet.
I was so computer illiterate.
I couldn't even know what I was doing.
I remember it had a crab,
literally a crab.
There was a default picture of a crab
in a beach.
And I was like, "That's fine."
And I put that there
(laughing)
and then made dotted
lines and it said 20% off
on a case of wine, non sale items.
I printed 100 of them, came
to the store the next day,
parked my car, ran in, opened the store,
told one of the kids to
keep an eye on the shop,
and drove to the short hills mall,
and literally put those
flyers on windshields
for an hour and a half.
What's fun about that for me here now is
day one Vayner was super funny.
And
the reality is I knew nothing
about the advertising industry
and I had to learn it.
And I had to build.
And so it's fun for me to
be challenged to remember
what I did,
knowing there's a wide
range of people here
who are a one-woman shop,
to people that are trying
to go from seven to eight figures.
Very honestly, I wanna really move this
into a very aggressive Q&A session
because I think just based
on how many people hit
me up on LinkedIn and
on Twitter over the last
24 hours about this,
the far majority of this
room at least has some level
of context of what I'm gonna
talk about or what I believe.
And I don't think that
brings you the most value.
I think what brings you the most value
is probably ironically, and
it's fun to see Maribel here
who I've worked very closely
with for quite a long time,
I'm extremely proud of
my operational capability
for all those incredible
things that I heard
in the intro just now,
which are super fancy
and really surreal for me to think about.
What I promise every one of you,
when I think about business,
that I'm most proud of
is 21 years ago, I walked
into my dad's store
and he decided,
'cause he was passionate about it,
to renovate the house.
This is like family business
shit and I was in charge.
Now, I'd been in the
business since I was 14.
Every weekend, every summer
vacation, my dad knew
that I wasn't a schlemiel
and that I was capable.
And even the last two years of college,
I was coming home almost every weekend,
putting in work.
But I walked in
and from that day to this second,
I have not raised capital.
I have had a payroll to make.
What blows my mind, this
is not true with Vayner,
because of the scale,
but I didn't even have a
credit line for Wine Library
and our invoices were due on 30 days
or the distributor would put you on COD,
cash on delivery, which would
stop you from being able
to buy from any of the distributors.
The discipline that I was raised in
to
pay with what you had.
Right?
And so I've scrapped.
I'm most proud
that for 21 straight years,
I've had to make payroll
and I have.
Operations.
Building an actual business.
So a lot of fancy other things
have come along the way,
but the connection point
I feel for this room
is quite high.
I have a lotta thoughts
about offense and defense,
which is playing out in all of your minds.
And so I'd like to bring
as much value as possible.
So there's two mics that are lined up,
so I think it's a good idea to line up.
Good.
And I think just to create
a little more framework
for the Q&A, I know you wanna come out
and frame the Q&A.
I just love having you here.
That was such a good intro.
- [Man] Oh, really?
Thank you.
- Yeah, it's really good.
(laughing)
- [Man] Can I say one thing?
- Yeah, say three things.
- So you said this,
there was a disclaimer
where somebody's like,
"Hey, you're gonna have to
go out here and tell people
that Gary likes to say the F word a lot,
but then I was like,
"Man, swearing is an intelligence thing,
"marks intelligence."
So I was like, "You bet your butt we are."
Right?
You know?
- I appreciate it.
- That's like a dumb thing.
(laughing)
- And listen,
Ryan told me back stage watch my mouth,
so I've thrown one shit out
and I've kept it fairly clean.
I'm pretty pumped,
but I know somebody's gonna
ask a fuckin' stupid question.
(laughing and clapping)
And I'm joking, 'cause
there is no stupid question.
On a very serious note,
and what I wanna set the tone on,
and this is where I wanna
inspire a couple of people
that are still sitting
'cause they're either more introverted,
or lazy, or who the hell
knows why you didn't get up.
I
am really passionate about operations
and how to build an actual business.
And it's very hard to
produce content for that,
that can bring enough value and
that's why I don't go there.
Listen, I think a lot of
you have a sense of me.
There was a very long time
where I went nowhere close
to anything motivational
'cause I have zero
point zero interest in
being a motivational speaker
even though I know many,
many people view me that way.
I'm motivated.
I'm optimistic.
I'm deeply grateful and happy.
And I genuinely do
believe that perspective
really, really matters.
Because if you think you've
lost before you've started,
you actually already lost and that's real.
'Cause that happens to me in things.
So
I have that in me, but I promise you,
please feel free to go very detailed.
I don't have a COO.
I have a thousand people.
I don't have a COO
'cause I'm operating it.
I'm making tangible operational decisions
in the back room right now.
I've just been very, very thoughtful
of how to create content at
scale and post produced it,
contextual to the platforms that matter.
But that doesn't take away
from the fact that I'm spending
11-14 hours a day being the CEO and COO
of a thousand-person global agency.
So I have some thoughts.
Started from scratch,
so
I can remember, and I understand,
and I know what has worked
for me and others that look like me
and what has kept a lot of
people at the $700,000 a year
in revenue business.
So I really think I can help.
So please fire away.
I'm honestly grateful to be
here and I appreciate it.
Thank you.
(applauding)
- [Robin] Hi, thank you, Gary.
My name is...
Is this on?
My name is Robin Wilson and
I sat there all day long
because I knew that this 55-year-old woman
would only have a chance of getting here
if I was closest to the
mic and in the front row.
So strategy pays (laughing)
(cheering and applauding)
- Hacking always works.
- [Robin] Woo, love it.
So I have
a specific question.
So I only do social media
marketing at our agency.
We only do social and
email, but social mainly
on that forefront.
But we serve a very particular vertical.
We serve automotive.
So we're a woman-owned business,
do social media marketing.
Their leader's 55 years old,
like any of that gives a shit
about anything, right?
And we not only just serve
the automotive industry,
but we really kind of niche
with subprime dealerships.
That's kinda where our forte is,
is that non-intender market.
And so my question has been
because people ask me all the time,
"Do you guys do digital also?"
Which means search.
And we don't because my
brain is only so big.
And so I don't know whether I
need to partner with somebody
or just continue
to let them find their
outsourcing for that
because all digital isn't right.
- I understand and do
you do paid and creative?
Or just paid and just creative?
- [Robin] Paid and creative.
- Understood.
So I think the answer
is extremely personal.
I think you and everybody else here
is not unaware that when
you don't provide a service,
it creates a vulnerability
that can lead to you
losing your service, right?
- [Robin] Right.
- Not super complicated.
We've all been there.
I think it comes down to,
and this is actually...
Thank you, Robin.
This is a great way to start.
I'd literally backstage, just made a video
and for the people that
follow me the most,
I'm in such post production,
film-my-life mode
that the days of five or six
years ago when I'd go straight
to camera with a thought video is rare.
Original programming just for the video
is rare for me these days,
but I'm so compelled right now
around this thought that
people are not self-aware
of what makes them happy
when they run a business.
And everybody just thinks about growth
without realizing the next employee
or the next hundred
dollars is the beginning
of the process of you not
liking your business anymore.
And that's your answer.
Your answer is predicated on
you know it's a vulnerability.
In one way, it's also a
strength in another way.
You just have to ask yourself
are you happy with the level
of business that you're at
and if you're not, are you in a place
where you think you can
get more deep narrow,
or do you think you
need to go wide, right?
Partnering is no.
Right?
All partnerships are
vulnerable from the get.
It's inconceivable that
another business or human
has the same exact interest as you do
and something's gonna happen eventually.
Again, this is what makes this fun.
The heads are nodding 'cause ya lived it.
You already thought about the
shit you did that didn't work.
Right?
So that's why we never
partnered with anybody.
As a matter of fact, I
never took a single meeting
to partner with anybody
because I knew I was gonna do everything
'cause I'm building it for myself.
And I had no interest
claiming that they're the one
that told me to do...
I didn't even wanna make myself vulnerable
to somebody claiming that in
a meeting they were trying
to get me to partner with them
that when I then did what
they did, I was a dick.
So I wouldn't even take the meetings
'cause I didn't want the
reputational vulnerability
'cause I knew there was
never gonna be a scenario
where I was gonna partner with anybody.
I was gonna do everything.
- [Robin] Perfect answer.
Thank you.
- You know,
it's a self awareness answer.
Let me say one other thing
'cause in know this will
bring more value to everybody.
I'm also a very big fan when
you wanna do something else,
to not do yesterday's
thing, to do tomorrow's.
I would much rather a lot of people here
who are in social only, not
go and do search and banner,
and programmatic, but start the process
of affording the ability
to do voice in four years.
'Cause their business will grow much more.
- [Robin] Love it.
Thank you--
- But real quick.
And I apologize.
(laughing)
- [Robin] I'm coming back.
- But the reason I say voice
is think voice is dangerously close,
whereas if you come up to me and say...
The next guy was like,
"Gary, that's exactly right."
I'm gonna be doing blockchain advertising
to guarantee consumption.
I'm like that's further
along than you think.
Or I'm building a VR shop.
Not one person you know
goes home and does VR,
which means we're far away.
(laughing)
My strength is timing,
not just seeing it.
Right?
I'm not talking about
TikTok a whole bunch now
'cause I just fuckin' discovered it.
I was one of the first
users of Musical.ly.
I'm talking about it now
'cause it's on the cusp
of getting older and that's
why I've talked about Snapchat
even though I invested four years earlier.
I wait 'til things hit a
different level of scale
that encompanies more consumers.
Timing.
The reason Vayner got so big
was I invested in the things
that I thought would be
soon and I stayed alive
with my salesmanship to get there.
- [Robin] Yes.
Thanks.
- Thank you.
(applauding)
- Eric] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Eric] I'm great,
man, how are you doing?
- Very good, what's your name?
- [Eric] My name is Eric Yang.
- Eric.
I'm from Paris.
- Very nice.
- [Eric] And actually built
a online conference agency.
And we actually operate in Los Angeles.
And I've actually been
following your advice,
which is creating content and
documenting entire journey
and process of our work.
- I love it.
- [Eric] And it actually
has been working really,
really well for us.
- Go figure.
(laughing)
- [Eric] What's been interesting
it the type of people
that follow us now are mostly
entrepreneurs that are Asian,
under 30--
- Makes sense.
- which is exactly who I am.
And I actually moved to Asia to be closer
with that demography.
- Interesting.
- [Eric] And my question to you is,
besides podcasting, what
advice would you give
entrepreneurs in Asia to
build a personal brand?
- Well, I think podcasting's
gonna have a huge growth
in that area.
I also think that KOLs are
disproportionately advanced
in Asia, especially in mainland
China and other places.
So the ability to tap into
the influencer ecosystem
in that world is quite advanced.
I also think that there's
enormous arbitrage
on all the social networks
out in South-East.
So we opened up Singapore
because we think the media costs
on Instagram, and Facebook,
and the platforms that play,
even Line when we go full-time
to Japan and South Korea,
are even more under-priced
than they are in America.
Our global expansion has
been completely predicated
on the under-priced nature of the media
that we most believe in.
So the answer is it doesn't change.
My answer is always the same.
What are humans doing?
And then bring them the
most value in that channel.
I mean, again, I know a lot
of you are following at home.
The fact that Crushing It
only came out 18 months ago
as a book, and spoke nothing
of LinkedIn and LinkedIn
is that top thing I'm
talking about is wild.
Here's why it's wild.
It's not a new thing, it
just became under-priced.
There's a very dark-horse
chance that I'm gonna talk
a lot about print and direct mail, radio,
and television one day
because the market's so collapses
that the price becomes actually a deal.
I want to buy outdoor
billboards when they're remnant
and I can buy 'em for two months for $2000
instead of $34,000.
I'm unemotional.
I can't wait to be at a
conference in seven years
and completely shit on social media.
(laughing)
Because you have to understand.
I wasn't making content and
you weren't following along
when I built my entire companies on...
Guys, I ran ads on Google
the day it came out.
I bought Google AdWords
for five cents a click
the day it came out for wine terms.
That was one of the biggest
reasons my library grew.
I did email marketing in 1997, heavy.
It was my religion.
I had 90 fuckin' percent open rates.
It was unheard of.
But it was new.
The same rate right now,
I'm getting a million,
I'm 100s and if not, 1000s of emails a day
or DMs from people that are thanking me
for telling them to go on TikTok.
It's just arbitrage.
But people dig in on the thing they know
and aren't willing to kill
the thing that got 'em there.
That's what's happening in this room.
You're not willing to kill the thing
that got you to the dance
when it no longer is the thing.
And so you start justifying
and you start shitting
on the new thing,
which gets you deeper in the hole.
Then you feel even further behind.
That's the game.
- [Audience Member] Preach.
- That's the game.
- [Eric] Thank you.
- You got it.
- [Eric] (mumbles) just
to take a shot at this.
I am about to launch a podcast.
I have six guests lined up already.
Will you be open to be my seventh guest
for 15 minutes?
(laughing)
- Two minutes?
- [Eric] 15.
- No.
(laughing)
- [Eric] What about two?
Just two minute, one question.
- You made a critical
mistake and I'll explain it.
If you had booked four guests,
I would have definitely done it.
- [Eric] Six people are lined up already.
They're prerecorded.
- Yeah, I get it.
But if I could have been the fifth guest,
I would be in.
Now I'm gonna wait to
be the hundredth guest.
(laughing)
- [Eric] So when I have 100.
- When you get 99 in the
bag, you send me this clip
and I'll do it.
- [Eric] Done.
Thank you.
(cheering and applauding)
- [Smitty] Gary, it is always
good to see you, my friend.
- It's always good to see you, Smitty.
- [Smitty] I wanna thank you again.
I always do.
I send you emails regularly --
- I'm aware.
- [Smitty] to thank you.
(laughing)
- [Smitty] Something that's--
- I'm aware, I read 'em.
- [Smitty] I know.
And I appreciate you.
You answered one at 6:30 in
the morning on a Saturday
and I love you for that.
(laughing)
Following your advice has
helped me, as you know,
grow my company in two
and a half years from zero
to
a multimillion-dollar business.
- You didn't fully say it.
- [Eric] Huh?
- Go ahead.
Go ahead.
- [Eric] And I gotta tell you.
I'm not nervous speaking
to Gary, I'm just so moved
because this guy is so real and so genuine
and actually cares.
Really fucking cares.
- Because it doesn't come out of mine.
The second you understand
how much abundance
is in the world, you will
change your behavior.
- [Smitty] Absolutely.
- I'm giving away all my best
advice for free at scale.
(laughing)
I mean, you know how many
people here have made money
by literally parroting it directly?
And I like that.
That's what I want you to do.
Of course I could have
all those customers.
I'm just not gonna get around to it.
Do you know how nice this is to hear?
Admiration trumps finances
every day of the week.
Go ahead.
- [Smitty] So
at dinner two years ago,
you asked me a question
and the question was
"Are you building this company to buy?
"To build it and hold it
"or to build it and sell it?"
- I remember.
- [Smitty] And now I wanna
get it to the next level,
to get it to $100 million - $150 million.
- Okay.
- [Smitty] For an exit.
- [Smitty] Trying to figure
out what our next move is.
- I need more context to understand.
I think building all these
companies here is actually...
To build a $100 million agency
you have to be in the HR business.
- [Smitty] Sure.
- You wanna get to the punchline?
I spend all my time in HR.
That's the answer.
We sell people.
And I don't understand how you don't...
You know how we make fun of,
Rachel probably covered it in some way,
but I'm not sure if she went there,
when we scrutinize in the BC community,
companies that are very good at CAC,
but suck at LTV, they loose.
You can acquire customers all day long,
but if you need to hold
onto them for four months
to make it pay off and they drop off
after two and a half months,
you're out of business.
And then when the price
of Instagram and Facebook ads go out
and your CAC has gone up,
you're really in deep shit.
Yet we don't talk about LTV.
Maribel, how many years
you been at Vayner?
- [Maribel] Five.
- I mean, these are real.
When I got into the business,
people... (laughs)
This is super funny
'cause now I'm thinking.
I forgot.
Lot's of people came to give me advice.
I'm a nice guy so I was cordial,
but in my brain I'm like, "Motherfucker.
(laughing)
"My business is gonna be
bigger than yours in 36 months
"and I don't even know what I'm doing yet.
So your advice is cool,
but everyone's like, "Your
people are gonna stay
"for 18 to 24 months."
I'm like, "No, no, your people
"are gonna stay for 18 to 24 months.
"My people are gonna stay
for five, 10, and 15 years
"'cause I actually give
a fuck about them."
The only way you can build a
$100 million business is...
The reason New York Jets
are in big trouble right now
is their offensive line has no cohesion
because they don't every
play together at any level.
Agencies are like offensive lines;
they need cohesion.
You know how fast you can
go when everybody feels safe
and knows what everybody else is good at?
Yet people are fearful
that they're gonna...
I remember one of the things
I established early on.
If we lose an account, nobody gets fired.
'Cause I remember knowing
that I had to establish that.
Shit like that.
All the stuff that nobody's talking about.
It's very fascinating to me.
I'm Enigma.
I do unusual things.
I talk about my unusual things,
but everybody wants to
focus on other stuff
'cause the stuff I do is hard.
People.
- [Smitty] And just one final follow-up.
Don't listen to what he says,
execute on what he does.
Watch what he does and do it.
I've built my company
following his advice and
doing exactly what he roadmaps
and he gives away his best shit.
I directly owe you.
There's not enough Wine
Library, Wine Text,
Empathy,
I subscribe to all of them.
I know you know that too.
I do that because there's
not enough thank yous
that I can give you
for the value you've given me.
- I'm trying to guilt
every fuckin' person on earth
and (mumbles) shit.
- [Smitty] Great job.
- Thank you.
- [Smitty] Thanks, Gary.
- [Trevor] Hey, Gary.
- Hey.
- [Trevor] My name's Trevor.
Unlike the gentleman before you.
I am pretty nervous,
so I got a stress ball
- Squeezing the ball?
- From my friend, Eric.
- No worries.
(laughing)
- [Trevor] Give it back,
but the reason why I
wanted to come up here
to say thank you,
I found your content a couple years ago
from the Monday Morning Rant video
that you run all the time.
And the 400 trillion to
one kinda really got me.
'Cause right when that video came out,
I lost my mother to a two-year
multi-battle to cancer.
- I'm sorry to hear that.
- [Trevor] I realized there's
no reason to do shit ya hate.
- None.
- [Trevor] So I wanted--
- And by the way, 25-50% of this room
hates what they're doing right now.
- [Trevor] That was me.
That was honestly me
and you really changed my life.
So what I did was I got into...
I'm like, "I'm a ninja with SEO.
"I'm gonna go give my
services away for free,"
'Cause there's no way for
me to go into a business
be like, "Yeah, I've done nothing,
"but I'm gonna make you money."
So I reverse engineered that
because of what you said
and I ended up doing a lot of business
for companies and raising a lot of money.
And people are like,
"How much do we owe you?"
I'm like, "I don't know.
"I'm just here to make a brand."
But I've done a poor job
at building my own brand.
That's mainly my question
'cause now I'm ready to start scaling
'cause my goal is to give back.
Formed 501C3, formed a non for profit,
started Chancellor Charity
on behalf of my mom
who grew up with literally nothing
and gave everything she had.
So it really inspired me.
- Makes sense.
- So a lot like your content.
But now I'm ready to kind of...
In order to do that
since I'm working--
- Yeah, but the good news is,
you did build your brand.
You executed.
- [Trevor] I did.
- So you're actually
in a much better place
than a lot of people
who've done a good job
amassing followers, but
don't actually do shit.
- [Trevor] I don't have
a lot of followers,
but the companies I do have,
they trust me.
They'll give their left kidney for me.
- Correct.
And so you should probably
take it and sell it
on the black market.
(laughing)
Take those... I'm just kidding.
Listen, what is old is always new.
I think testimonials are powerful.
I don't think they should be boring
like we saw in the '90s,
but I think you have built your brand.
Every time big agency holding
companies try to razz on me,
and pay the card of, "Well, it's all Gary
"and his relationships."
And I'm like, "Yes, GE and Pepsi,
"and Chase and ABI are so enamored with me
"that they're seven, and six,
and eight-year clients of us."
They're clients with us
because they've gotten results.
'Cause we execute.
Yes, maybe I've been more out and about,
about how I've approached
it, but you built your brand,
you just haven't now manifested the equity
that you're sitting with.
And this is what I will tell you
for everybody here that's
looking for new business,
this moment on LinkedIn, many
of you felt the good effects,
many of you regretted
for not jumping on board
of the golden era of Facebook
organic reach on pages.
Right?
- [Trevor] That's true.
- We can all agree on that?
You know of it one way or the other.
You either benefited from it,
or you kinda wish you took advantage of it
when I was screaming about it
and most people weren't doing it.
I'm gonna give you
another chance right now.
It's happening right now.
It's called LinkedIn.
LinkedIn is Facebook 2011.
Right now.
You can have no followers,
nobody knows you.
You make a video, a
picture, a written word,
a deck, a something, you post it,
and a lot more people than
you think will see it.
You're welcome.
(applauding)
- [Trevor] Thank you, Gary.
Means the world, man.
- LinkedIn, testimonials.
By the way,
not everybody is remarkably
handsome and charismatic.
- [Trevor] I can't be Gary Vee.
- So not everybody needs to be (laughs)...
Find out how you communicate.
One of the reasons I
started making cartoons,
which I think some of you've
seen on LinkedIn or Instagram,
is 'cause I keep trying
to find ways to show you
that there's a million
ways to communicate.
You don't have to have gift for gab,
one-take improv ability to go.
You might write incredibly well
and you seven paragraphs
on the current state
of longtail SEO, post on
LinkedIn and get the hell out
and see three inbound leads is real.
And it will go away
because I'm yelling loud.
Half will do it, some will
do it, one will do it,
da-da-da-da-da-da-da
and then it will get saturated.
The attention will be matched
by the amount of content.
Ads will go into the ecosystem.
You understand?
How many times do you
have to see this happen?
(laughing)
Right?
How many times do you need...
How do you think I dominated social?
I lived it with search
and with email, and then I'm
like, "Okay, now I get it.
"I'm not making the same mistake."
When I see it (clicks tongue)...
You know how many people here
are struggling to get leads
and win RFPs and get new business?
And literally, the answer
is LinkedIn right now.
And now I've said it
and still 74% of you
next week won't do it,
which is how I got into insecurity,
and parenting, and perspective, right?
'Cause I couldn't logically understand
how this is happening right
now and I know 74% of you
are not gonna do it next week.
I'm like, "Oh, right.
"They're scared of judgment.
"Oh, right, they don't want their uncle
"to say they're stupid or when
some anonymous person says
"that they're ugly, that kills them.
"Right, they didn't get
the luxury of circumstance
"and parenting that I had.
"So now let me give it to them."
I just wanna be the collective shield.
Blame it on me.
(laughing)
No, no, I'm serious, bro.
Let's just do it right
now once and for all.
When--
What's that?
- [Audience] Gary did it.
- Just blame it on me.
When somebody leaves a comment
and says you're stupid.
Tell 'em I told you to post it.
(laughing)
Tag me.
I will go in there and
rip that fucker apart.
(cheering and applauding)
- [Trevor] Thank you, Gary.
- [Jeff] Hey, Gary.
- Seriously.
Yeah, hey, how are you?
- [Jeff] I'm just fantastic.
I have to tell you I spoke
a little bit earlier,
right before you
and I'm so glad I didn't
have to speak after (laughs).
- Thank you.
- [Jeff] But I really
enjoy what you're doing.
And I have to say one of the things
that's challenged my question,
so I work with experts.
I help them become more of an authority
and I help them become
influence of the space.
So a lot of what we do is
actually Gary Vee-type stuff
and actually, confession
number two, I actually spoke
at digital marketer's headquarters,
teaching a content strategy
that looks a little bit like
yours, that you talk about.
- That free deck I put out
has made a lotta people
a lotta fuckin money.
- [Jeff] Yeah.
No joke, you guys, how to leverage a video
and turn it into quote
images and social media posts
and all that stuff
and use Square platforms so
you can put it on Instagram,
Facebook, LinkedIn and everything
and just get the most
leverage outta your content,
my question to you is
one of those problems
that I do have, 'cause the
experts that I work with,
they're running businesses.
Mostly, they're CEOs, founders,
or agency owners.
- Makes sense.
- [Jeff] The problem that I
have, it's like pulling teeth
getting them to create this content,
to invest in their own personal brands.
- That's why I invented
Document, Don't Create.
- [Jeff] Tell me more.
- They should film their day.
- [Jeff] Okay.
So I totally get that--
- People are busy.
- [Jeff] Yeah, they're busy and so--
- Or they have to start a podcast,
which becomes the top of the funnel
for the post production
creative across the board.
- [Jeff] Smart.
- With neither, you can't.
Just so everybody knows,
unless you're vlogging,
or you do a podcast,
or you decide to become
a guest on people's,
one of my best arbs is
being a guest on people's.
You think I wanna talk to the Paris dude
at fuckin' episode 100?
(laughing)
But here's why it works.
I get to win twice.
I know, and it makes me feel
good that when he has me on,
his guest from episode
101 on are gonna be better
'cause he's gonna leverage
that I was a guest.
That makes me feel nice.
Number two, when I do that interview,
I'm gonna be filming it.
He's gonna ask me a question
that's gonna take me
in a direction that maybe I
wouldn't have gone otherwise.
That answer becomes a piece of content
that gets a million views on Instagram.
- [Jeff] Perfect.
So the follow-up question is to any client
who is reluctant on creating that content,
I'm gonna send 'em this video.
What would you tell 'em if they tell me,
"Jeff, I don't have time."?
Well, then you don't get the
benefits of the opportunity.
- [Jeff] There it is.
- It's not super complicated.
That's great.
Don't have time to go to the gym?
You're fuckin' fat.
(laughing)
Have time, you aren't.
Don't have time to
spend a lot of hours with your children
and give them wisdom and love?
You might have a more
challenging relationship
when they're older.
Don't have time?
Don't get results.
What I would tell them is
they're making decisions
and valuing something that's less valuable
than this for the growth
of their business.
- [Jeff] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applauding)
- [Dre] What's happening, Gary.
- Life is good.
- [Dre] I'm Dre Harris from Arizona.
- It's a real pleasure.
- [Dre] Yeah, I been dreaming
about asking you a question.
I've watched like 600 of
your videos probably--
- Thank you, bro.
- so yeah, I'm a fan.
But I would consider myself
like a recovering bro marketer,
if you will, right?
I was like a total whore
for every marketing tactic
trick of the day.
- I get it.
- [Dre] All that bullshit, right?
- Yep.
- And so your content, in large part,
has really been the catalyst--
- Can I tell you about that real quick?
- Yeah.
- Cause it's
gonna bring value.
I always love that story,
because what made you that guy,
when deployed against
something more meaningful,
is gonna create results.
- I believe it.
- I see it all the time.
You know?
It's just a discipline change.
- [Dre] Absolutely.
So your content, in large
part, has been the catalyst
for me and my business
partner really changing
how we've been building the business
for the last 18 months.
- Makes me happy.
- And so--
- How's it going?
- [Dre] Well, it's going well.
We're giving away a lotta free shit.
So talk to me in a year
or something (laughs).
- I get it.
- [Dre] And so you talk
about giving away your
best stuff for free.
I thing one of your recent quotes was
"Fuck your seven-day trial."
And so you--
(laughing)
- Let me explain.
No, let me explain.
I think it will help.
I'm not against seven-day trials.
I'm against the fact that
the seed of the intent
of that seven-day trial
was to get somebody in,
give them nothing, to make them pay.
- [Audience member] There it is.
You're right.
- That's it.
We are unbelievable
incapable of not thinking
about ourselves first.
And so when somebody comes a long
that thinks about it the other way,
she or he can disrupt.
That deck that I put out
that a lotta people are making money on
took money out of people
who sell $1,800 decks.
That makes me happy.
(laughing)
- [Dre] No doubt.
- Now, if that deck is valuable,
mazel tov, but the reality is we've gotten
into a place in internet marketing
where that is not the
case 98% of the time.
And that's something that I think
should be disrupted.
No different than taxi cabs or bookstores.
If you do not bring value
to the end consumer,
you should be disrupted.
Go ahead.
- [Dre] Yeah, so you talked a lot recently
in some of your videos
about who ever can hold
their breath the longest
is gonna win.
And so
can you kind of elaborate
on that a little bit?
- Yes, whoever feeds their
customer and their business
instead of extracting it so
that they can buy dumb shit
to impress people they don't even like
tends to build better
wealth in businesses.
- [Dre] Done.
Thanks.
- I just don't understand that.
There's so many people
here running smaller...
The reason so many people's shops here
are smaller than they think
is they're taking too
much money out of it.
Of course you can't scale.
You're not hiring anybody
'cause you're buying stuff.
There's not a person in this room,
me included, that uses every
room in the homes they own.
(laughing)
I think about that shit a lot.
I'm like, "Fuck,
"we don't use any of these rooms.
"I wish I had the money back for..."
You know?
That's how I got to that whole house thing
that everybody got mad at me for.
Go ahead.
- [Man] I live in a studio.
I use all my space.
(laughing)
- Let's go!
- [Man] Minimalist, man, minimalist.
- Let's fucking go.
- [Man] How ya doing, man?
- You really put me
in a good mood.
- [Man] Good, good!
- That was a great fuckin' start.
Go ahead.
- [Man] My dog doesn't
like it so much, but I do.
- I get it.
- [Man] So I quit my job--
- Your dog might fuckin' love it.
- [Man] My dog might?
He comes to the office--
- He doesn't talk to you about it.
(laughing)
- [Man] True, true.
You might analyze the
barking and the obvious, but
(laughing)
people are confused by me all the time.
- [Man] Yeah, same, man.
Same.
- Seriously.
I think about that quite a bit.
By the way, I'm gonna just build on that.
Back to producing content,
there are so many people that tune me out
the first time they see me
because of the way I say
something, not what I'm saying.
They misinterpret the
conviction or the energy.
Plus, I'm very different here
on stage where I have the mic
than I am when I...
I mean, I'm sure, Maribel,
you've had to say that
a million times.
The way I interact on a
one-on-one level is so different.
It's just the nature of the context of it.
There's a part of me that
just watched too much
Randy the Macho Man Savage.
(laughing)
And Richard Pryor that has now manifested
in a bullshit version of those two in one.
And so I think that
your dog might love it.
- [Man] Thanks, man.
I'll let him know.
I'll let him know Gary Vee says that.
- Go ahead.
- [Man] Yeah, so I quit my
job like three years ago
to jump into entrepreneurship full-time.
Fell flat on my face two times.
And then LinkedIn released video.
Right?
And since then, I was
one of the first creators
and my company's gone...
I've literally gone from
-$900 in my bank account
to my company is about
to pass seven figures.
So one, I wanted to say thank you.
Two, this is a weird question.
You said this,
someone's gonna ask
something fucking weird.
This is it.
Can I have a hug?
- Hell yeah.
- [Man] I tried
to get you earlier, man.
- Hell yeah, let's go.
(cheering and applauding)
- Awesome.
- You're the shit, dude.
- I'm proud of you, bro.
- You're the shit.
- I'm proud of you.
Let's go! (laughs)
Hold on one second, I
don't think they turned on.
Go ahead.
Not yet.
- [Rafael] Hi, Gary.
This is Rafael from Mexico.
- Hi, Rafael.
- [Rafael] I just saw
that you launched your YouTube on Spanish.
What opportunities you are seeing
to start developing content in Spanish
to US companies?
- Well, there's a lotta people that
speak and understand Spanish.
(laughing)
- [Rafael] Yeah, but what
makes you take the next step?
- What made me do that?
- [Rafael] Yeah.
- The fact that I'm building
enough of a business
that I can afford more employees
so that I can get people
onto the next initiative.
- [Rafael] Okay, yeah.
- I wanna remind everybody
who uses the excuse
that Gary has a team, that
I did it all by myself
for nine years without one employee.
And for all the OG...
How many people here were
active on Twitter in 2007,
eight, nine, 10, 11?
Raise 'em.
You all know
who was putting out the
most replies and content.
What did I see?
I always wanted to do it.
I just systematically
went to each initiative
that's my top priority.
And eventually had enough scale on my team
to get into the transcription
at scale that I needed.
- [Rafael] So you think
it's a good opportunity
to start producing content?
US company to Hispanic market?
- Yes, I do.
- [Rafael] Perfect.
- I think
anybody who's confused
by the growth of Latin flavor in our...
It's funny.
When I hear people talk
about having a division...
And it's really fun to have you, Maribel,
'cause we had a lot of
these conversations.
Maribel has incredible
passion for her heritage
and her community like many do.
I would always say to her, like,
"We're not building a division.
"This is America."
(applauding and cheering)
So I think it's a huge opportunity.
And when you start digging
and looking at the metrics,
(speaks Spanish), I also think Spanglish
is an incredible place
where some of the content
is half Spanish, half English.
They're incredible opportunities.
I'm so fuckin' pissed
I was born in Russia.
If I could have been born in
a Spanish-speaking country,
I'd be fuckin' dominating.
(laughing)
- [Rafael] (speaks Spanish)
- See, I don't know
what the fuck you said.
(laughing)
- [Man] Hi, how are you?
Love your content.
- By the way, another one for the people
that really read my content,
you know how much I love
showing my report card.
I got real Ds and Fs in languages.
I failed German one, two times in a row.
Literally, freshman and sophomore year.
And in New Jersey at the time,
you had to pass two years of language
to graduate high school.
I failed German one horribly
both freshman and sophomore year
on the thesis that German
was just like Russian.
And then thank God, big
shout out to Mrs. Kennedy,
my Spanish teacher.
I literally know three words in Spanish.
She called my mom four
days before I graduated
and said, "Mrs. Vaynerchuk,
I know we never spoke
"and I just wanted you to know
"that your son is gonna pass
and graduate high school,
"but you need to know, he
doesn't know a fuckin' word.
(laughing)
- [Man] First of all,
I love your content.
I started watching you originally
when I got into wine and kosher wine
by wine library with Daniel Rogoff
and all those wine reviews.
- I remember.
- Very good.
- Thank you.
- [Man] On behalf of my
community, I'm Orthodox.
Everybody wants to know
when I'm gonna get a kosher
to sign on in Empathy Wines.
- That's a great, great question.
The truth is I don't
know the answer to that,
but I get inspired by stuff like this.
If you email me at gary@vaynermedia,
I will put in a folder
in my (mumbles) thing
and when I go and have those meetings,
that's what I look at.
And I will ask the question
of how we're thinking about
it and things of that nature,
'cause Nate and Trout are really
driving a lot of that boat.
But the answer is we're talking a lot
about Empathy right now
from sparkling seltzer,
to cans, to kosher, to a
lotta different conversations.
So it's a great time to ask the question.
- [Man] Okay, awesome.
Another thing, I noticed on LinkedIn
and with all your media, you're
very into being yourself.
That's who I am, et cetera.
I noticed the past six months,
maybe a little bit longer on LinkedIn,
the curse words are beeped out.
How come?
- I believe that I wanna community-manage
when people are pushing back.
And the LinkedIn community,
over a
long period of time,
really was getting quite loud at scale
about the cursing.
And the reality is I believe
equally in being yourself
and always never being bigger
than the audience itself.
So
the beeping out is because
I genuinely believe
that it was becoming
detrimental to the message
and I didn't have the time
like I did back in the day
to, every time it was out,
to go in and community manage
and reply to 44 people
and apologize that,
that's throwing them off,
but telling them why
it was important to me.
So I feel like I'm still being myself.
It's beeped.
You know what I'm fuckin' saying.
(laughing)
So that's where I'm at.
- [Man] Okay, awesome.
Just for the last question.
So I have an ad agency
and I manage clients
for couple thousand dollars a month.
Lots of times, if a client comes to me,
I'm managing their social media.
They're paying me $2,000-3,000 a month.
Like, "By the way, could you
design this brochure for us?"
And by nature I'm just a giving person.
I like to say yay and no problem,
I'll do that for you for free.
Not charge anything extra.
But on the other hand,
I understand that if
people don't pay for it,
they don't value it.
So where do you draw the line?
- Whatever your stomach is at the moment.
There's no right answer to this question.
The amount of times I've
done things for free
that ended up being
extremely right is enormous.
And the amount of times
I've done things for free
that ended up being a path
of being overly taken advantage of
that ultimately had
negative repercussions,
including burnt out staff
and many other things,
has been often as well.
I tend to be like, "Yeah."
People are like,
"Gary, you always talk about
giving and all this stuff,
"but I'm being taken advantage of."
I'm like, "You're choosing
to being taken advantage of."
Everybody's a big girl and boy in here.
You're more than welcome to say no.
And we're about to go
through a big transformation
at Vayner Media.
We're creating a very
uncomfortable minimum fee
for a yearly retainer
or we're not gonna talk to you.
That's just where we're at now.
That's what I think is the right thing.
So I think it's a personal question
and I think you should test both.
I always tell people ask
for a little bit more money
on the next scope just
as a testing mechanism
because a lot of you
have subjectively decided
on your ceiling.
Or one person said no and you're like,
"Fuck, the market doesn't want it."
No, no, one person doesn't want it.
- [Man] Awesome, thank you.
- You got it, bro.
- [Salvador] Hey, Gary,
how you doing, man?
- Very well, bro.
- [Salvador] My name is Salvador.
First of all, I wanna say thank you, man,
just for being here, for
everything that you share.
I moved from Cuba two years
ago and I learn English
listening to your podcast, man.
(cheering and applauding)
I learn how to say
motherfucker, man (laughs).
(laughing)
- I get it.
That's amazing, Salvador.
Thank you so much for that honor.
How can I help you?
- [Salvador] So my question...
(laughing)
We are using an influencer
to promote our brand
and
people
that interact with our
ads and with our posts,
they just interact with the influencer.
We split
as we do videos, photos, you know.
But people continuing to
act with the influencer.
What we could do to--
- Fire the influencer.
- [Salvador] Yeah, thank you so much, man.
(laughing)
- You never want somebody
else to have leverage
more than you have the leverage.
If you feel like it's gotten out of hand,
you need to fire the influencer.
Get a different influencer.
I think a lot of people
should create influencers,
either in themselves...
One big thing that I love,
if you have any animation
skills in yourself,
or within your organization,
way more people need to get
into the Mickey Mouse business.
Your influencer can be a cartoon
and you get to own the...
The cartoon doesn't get drunk.
The cartoon doesn't have
sexual harassment issues.
The cartoon doesn't become a prima donna
and want more money.
The cartoon is something you own.
Lil' Vee that I put out,
and there's only one of 'em,
that wasn't for kicks and giggles.
I don't do anything for kicks and giggles.
Animation is something to consider.
Or understand it's 2019 and
it's not about production value.
Putting your head on a stick figure,
literally drawing a stick figure
and putting your head on it
and then having post-production
animation skills
and doing voiceovers
so that you could do
tons of things visually,
but you don't have to
be actually doing them,
there's another good free idea.
I'm loaded with ideas.
This is about fuckin' execution.
- [Salvador] Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
You're welcome, brother.
(applauding)
- [Roseanne] So in 2009
I ran across this video
where a guy taught me
the best wine to have
with Froot Loops (laughs).
- I remember.
Thank you.
- [Roseanne] So I'm Roseanne.
I run Red Head Labs.
We are an eCommerce development firm,
mainly Shopify and Big Commerce.
My main question right now
is we are trying to convince brands
that TikTok is real and a good placement.
So how are you actually
convincing the brands
that you're working with
that, that's where money should be spent.
- By telling them and not
spending a second on it
when they say no.
The reason I went for the dramatic pause
(laughing)
is because I love you
for asking this question
because in the macro,
it is the biggest
vulnerability in the room.
The biggest vulnerability in this room
is trying to convince the unconvincible.
I've done new business meetings,
that are scheduled for
an hour, in 16 minutes
because as soon as I sensed it was over,
I wanted the 45 minutes back.
- [Roseanne] Yep.
- Many, thank you, many
of you and our industry
will have an 18th
meeting with that person.
I don't convince.
I put shit on the record
and then some people benefit
and others figure it out later.
- [Roseanne] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applauding)
- [Man] Hey, Gary.
First of all, big fan.
Thank you for being here.
- Thank you.
- [Marcel] So just for context,
my name is Marcel.
I run a company
that helps digital agencies
run more profitably
without wasting time on spreadsheets.
So we're about to launch B2B Sass.
About $3K ARR price point.
If you're in my shoes,
what's the strategy that
you're doubling down on
to start off with?
- Giving it away for free to
the most influential people
and then leveraging the fact
that they use it successfully.
- [Marcel] Okay.
Well, I guess you're getting
a free copy of our software.
(laughing)
- That's good!
Maribel?
And LinkedIn, bro.
LinkedIn.
I like when you ladder up a show,
maybe a podcast around efficiency.
Maybe a podcast called hidden costs.
If I was IDing, I would say,
"Bro, start a podcast
called hidden costs."
People make decisions
in the funniest ways.
They make decisions
without realizing there's hidden costs.
You know why I love culture?
Because rehiring somebody
has a lot of hidden costs.
People are like,
"I'm not gonna give you
a raise for $3,000."
And then the person leaves
and they spend $6000
to replace somebody that has no context.
That's fuckin' dumb.
Got it?
- [Marcel] Yeah.
- So if you start a
show called hidden costs
and you have different people on from HR,
from procurement to different
stuff, but the underlining
is the innuendo within the
title is that your product...
'Cause they're gonna know who you are.
You don't even need to
mention the company,
is that your company is eliminating
and creates efficiencies,
and eliminates hidden costs.
That's how I think about the world.
Level up your thesis
from a programming standpoint
that brings even more value
'cause all of us will listen
if it's 53 different topics
of hidden costs,
but if it's just sass, it won't.
You understand?
The show right now is called
the Agency Profit Podcast,
so it's a little bit
more literal--
- Next.
- [Marcel] But anyway.
- No, next because good.
Keep fuckin' going.
- [Marcel] Thanks, man.
- Now, post produce and
fuckin' quadruple down
on LinkedIn.
- [Marcel] Thanks, man.
- You got it.
- [Michael] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Michael] Doing good.
I'm Michael Ballwulf.
I'm coming from Creative House
and New York Marketing Association.
- Very nice.
- [Michael] So my question is
imagine that you have nothing,
except your mindset
and you're starting a
marketing agency today.
What direction you're gonna go?
What strategy gonna apply?
- So one of the things that you have to do
when somebody pays you
is you have to provide
value against that payment.
So if you're starting from scratch,
you need to sell
the thing that you think you're best at
no matter what it is.
So for me, what I'm best at
is observing human behavior
and understanding new ways to
get people to know something.
That's why social worked for me.
That's why if I was
starting today right now,
if this was a bizarre world
and today was day one,
everything's the same for me,
I'm just coming out of the business,
I would probably call
my company Vayner Voice.
Here's why.
I'm capable enough to sell
some consulting scopes
about where voice is going
to keep me around to
eventually be the best dev shop
on Alexa skills and Goggle Home
because I genuinely think
that the voice device
is the only potential, I do
not think it's guaranteed,
'cause I don't see the scale yet.
And this how I look about TikTok.
I don't think TikTok is...
I saw somebody mentioned
that I say Instagram's dead
and it's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying TikTok is the
first platform that I see
that has the potential
to become the next thing.
That's what I thought about Social Cam.
That's what I thought about Vine.
That's what I thought about Snap.
It's also what I thought
about Instagram and Facebook.
'Cause Myspace was fuckin' killing it.
(laughing)
So
that's what I would do.
But I have a pretty unique, awesome skill,
enough salesmanship and enough ability
to be right often enough in
a short enough period of time
to benefit from that.
What I would recommend is people
to do what they're best at.
And by the way, that is
what I did with Vayner.
Just so everybody knows,
the first two years of Vayner Media,
first two years of Vayner Media,
all we did was community
management on Twitter and Facebook.
That was our entire business.
Nothing else.
'Cause that's what I was best at.
I wasn't best at creative
on Twitter in 2009.
I wasn't.
I was great at community management.
- [Michael] Great.
One more question.
I made a bet with my friend
that I'm gonna shake hands with you.
- Let's go.
But I want half the fuckin' money.
(laughing)
Nice to meet you, my friend.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Nice to meet you.
- I'm a big fan.
Thank you, brother.
(applauding)
- [Gordo] Hi, Gary, this
is Gordo from India.
So I've been--
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gordo] Same here.
So I've been into the voice-first world
for about a year and a half.
- I'm sorry, one more time.
- [Gordo] I'm into the voice-first world
the voice of building Alexa skills,
the Google action for
one and a half years.
- Fantastic.
- And largely, the challenge
is that the discovery is
a huge pain in the ass.
- (blows raspberries)
- [Gordo] And the Google,
they don't share any data.
Alexa doesn't share any data, right?
So if you're looking at...
Saying that somebody is
gonna build a platform
on a product, which we are looking at.
We building production now,
or going to build production,
you know, in that phase right now.
In this space,
to solve our discovery problem--
- They're gonna solve it.
That's why the app store was built.
It was impossible to
find apps at first too.
They'll build it when
they feel like it's time.
Discovery's a piece of cake.
It's just at the mercy of the platform.
- [Gordo] Yeah, okay.
- The end.
- [Gordo] So if--
- Hold your fuckin' breath.
- [Gordo] somebody's
looking at the voice...
(laughing)
Somebody's looking at
the voice-first platform,
from a discovery point of
view, it's gonna be totally
on the mercy of Google and
Amazon of the world pretty much.
- Ish.
And now you're gonna understand
why I built a creative
and media shop because it solves that.
Our ability to create discovery
because of our ability to
create content at scale
that's contextual for every
platform and arbitrage
against the media costs
is greater than everybody else's on earth.
Thus, gives me the opportunity
to have a leverage point
against anybody who's
building Alexa apps right now.
Because I can create the
part that they can't,
they become the commodity
I have the leverage.
- [Gordo] Got it.
So if somebody's looking
at building a product
into this--
- But, real quick
and I apologize.
I only have the leverage
until Amazon flips the switch
and on amazon.com or on
every Amazon package,
or on Google's home page,
there's discovery for every app.
We lived this.
It was called Apple apps.
It wasn't hard.
The first year and a half,
there was no discovery.
And then there was.
- [Gordo] So somebody's
looking at building a product
into this space,
for a discovery in the voice space,
what do you suggest that would be?
- As a app for the consumer?
- [Gordo] Yeah.
You're not being an agency in dev shop,
you're building for yourself or consumer?
- [Gordo] Yep.
- Be great at discovery.
That's the punchline.
You know what I mean?
You have to add that capability.
Otherwise you just built a great app.
Tree in the forest.
Nobody knows you built the best app.
Somebody's gonna build
a better app in a year
'cause the capabilities
are gonna be better
and you're fucked.
And that's what happens all the time.
- [Gordo] Yep, all right.
Thank you.
- You got it.
(applauding)
- [Abram] Hey, Gary.
- Hello.
- [Abram] My name's Abram Gonzales.
I'm from Mexico--
- Am I gonna be...
I apologize, sir.
Am I gonna be able to
extend this a little bit?
Cool.
Go ahead.
- [Abram] Abram Gonzales from New Mexico.
Right now I'm the only
person that's client-facing
in my agency.
So I know the next hire
is gonna be something
like an account manager.
My question for you,
I do a lotta local networking.
That's how I get all my clients.
My question for you is how
do you gracefully transition
to giving them an account manager
when they're really obsessed with you?
- By not selling them me.
- [Abram] How did you frame
that from the beginning
with your agency?
'Cause I imagine a
lotta people come to you
thinking it's--
- Everybody.
- [Abram] "Gonna work with Gary!"
- Yeah, and then I'm like
not true.
(laughing)
Here's Maribel.
You can back phone me
if you pay enough.
By being unbelievably upfront.
Back to that gentleman who talked
about me always saying yes,
I'm telling you, everybody's
biggest vocab addition is no.
(person sneezes)
Bless you.
(laughing)
And it was really funny.
And some of you, if you're
very deep in my content,
you might know what I'm about to say next.
In Russian superstition,
when somebody sneezes
right after a statement,
it means it's true.
So I appreciate that sneeze.
(laughing)
'Cause it came after
a very important point
that could have been glossed over.
The biggest word
that everybody in this
room needs to add is no.
And it was hard at first
because I had no other leverage.
Now it's easier.
Vayner's real,
but at first it was me.
And this is Pepsi and GE,
this is not like, you know...
And I'm like, "Not me."
And they're like, "What?"
And I'm like, "Yep."
I'm like, I'm the CEO,
I'm building company.
I'm here.
Just by telling them the truth.
- [Abram] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(phone ringing)
Hey, guys, sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
212- 931- 5731.
Hit me up with a text.
(applauding)
- [E-Mark] Hi, Gary.
My name is E-Mark.
- E-Mark.
- Good to met ya.
- Nice to meet you.
- [A-Mark] And I'm A-Mark.
Not sure if you remember us, Gary.
About six weeks ago back in Chicago,
we gave you
one of these boxes.
- I do.
I do.
- [A-Mark] Wanted to make
sure you had fresh breath.
- Thank you.
- [A-Mark] Then in about
the last seven weeks,
we've sent you one each
week to each of the offices.
- There's a huge fuckin'
bag right outside my office.
- [A-Mark] That's fuckin' awesome.
We win.
(laughing)
So, Gary, about 20 floors up from here...
Before I get there.
Before I get there,
could I have Jason, Goldie,
Sammy, and Otta stand up for me?
So, Gary, we came out here his week
and instead of listening
to all the sessions,
we decided to say, "Fuck it,
let's go talk to strangers
"and meet some new people."
And we said, "Let's start a
podcast while we're at it.
"Why not?"
So these are our first four guests.
Will you be number five?
- Ahhh.
Yes!
- [A-Mark] Yeah!
- [E- Mark] Fuck yeah, woo!
(cheering and applauding)
- Well played.
Super good.
So good.
So fuckin' good.
- [A-Mark] That's it.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Go ahead.
- [Quentin] Hi, Gary, my
name is Quentin Gause,
Rochester, New York.
I played in the NFL for two years.
I'm a free agent right now.
I own Iron Visuals.
- I saw your tweet.
- [Quentin] All right.
- Imma watch it.
- [Quentin] You do watch.
- I watch it.
It's so funny, right?
Because one of the biggest
digs I get currently
is interrupting guests on the podcast,
which I'm atrocious at.
But it's funny why that is
and I've started doing better
in the last week or two,
explaining why it is
so that people don't completely hate me,
but the level of listening I do
is far greater than the talking I do.
And that's very confusing
because you see me talking all the time,
but I'm fuckin' listening, bro.
- [Quentin] I feel you.
- Go ahead.
- [Quentin] The question I have is
have you ever had a time where
you had a high-ticket client
come to you last minute,
and this is more in the video realm,
and they wanted to get some work done.
In my situation, it was a travel agency.
They wanted me to go
to Cartagena, Columbia
to go film for six days.
The client didn't respect my prices.
They were tryna low-ball me.
We didn't end up working together.
What have you done in that situation
to try to get the client to work with you?
- It's a mix of a lot of
things we've heard today.
I just kind of put my line in
the sand and I'm empathetic.
I try to explain to them why
I think the value is there,
but make them very comfortably
understand if they wanna go
in a different direction.
- [Quentin] All right.
Thank you.
- Negotiation's a very interesting game.
People overthink it of who's
gonna blink first or tactics...
Just business.
People have a price for something.
I'm always empathetic.
They may have a P & L issue.
They may value me way
more than I'm even asking,
but they can't for some other reason.
But to your credit,
you didn't think that,
that was an exchange.
On the flip side, when
your company's very early,
I think you eat crow at scale
because you need case studies.
You need context, you know?
- [Quentin] Makes sense.
- It just didn't work for
you and that's okay to.
There is no right answer.
- [Quentin] Yes, sir.
Appreciate it.
Kimbo says, "What's up," by the way.
- I love that.
Thank you, Bro.
(applauding)
- [Man] Hi, Gary, what's going on, man?
I just wanna say thank you.
It's been just awesome hanging out here.
- By the way, this is unbelievable.
So I'm so sad right now and happy.
Literally, I wanted to
extend this aggressively.
On the queue here it says, "Last question.
"Need to call your daughter."
So I gotta go.
But go quick.
I'm so sorry for everybody.
Just hit me up, but I clearly
use that to make you feel sad.
(laughing)
- [Man] It works.
So as a CEO, taking a
business working with clients
that are bringing in $50
million to $100 mill,
what was the mindset shift that you had
to work with the big boys,
the Fortune 500s?
- Nothing.
- [Man] Nothing.
I let them come to me by
being historically correct
with what their customer was going to do.
The reason I win
often
is because I'm not worried
about eh person in the middle.
Got it?
- [Man] Yeah.
I didn't change for them.
They changed for me.
Why?
Because I focused on you.
The end customer is the leverage,
not the relationship with the
person that writes the check
if you're playing long.
- [Man] Perfect.
Thanks.
Get to your daughter.
(applauding)
- I love you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[Man] Thanks, man appreciate it.